the worldview 3 satellite passes high
above the Australian outback it picks up
a baffling pattern of black spots in the
deserts and they look like big black
holes in the middle of the desert these
really stand out from everything else
they could be small bodies of water like
ponds or something like that
the image comes from near the isolated
opal mining colony of Coober Pedy on the
edge of one of the most barren
landscapes on earth the great Victoria
Desert this is right in the middle of
the driest desert of the driest state
and the driest continent in the world
very few people have been to coober pedy
but the select few who know it's secret
come for a very specific reason
they come to play golf the black circles
are in fact part of one of the hottest
golf courses in the world it was created
in 1976 when sports mad locals came up
with the idea to make grassless greens
it is trying but when you're down at
ground level it'll make sense because
put greens F here would be too expensive
for the amount of water that we need to
keep them looking nice instead of grass
the greens are made of sand rolled with
black motor oil to stop it from blowing
away in windy weather you use a right to
right where you're going to pop and
describe the dirt back so the next
people got a sort of even place to putt
on during the summer months it gets even
weirder
it's too hot during the day so we come
out at night and use glow-in-the-dark
balls you can see them for to 300 meters
away they're good to play is good fun
it's nice and cool at night
it's a uniquely Australian answer to the
question of golf in the desert why would
you go through all the trouble of
pumping water to make your greens green
when black sand will do I guess black is
the new green
[Music]
you